why did you decide to write the book
first of all
uh well as far back as like 2010 2012
somewhere around there i've been
following this guy uh
in what was
known as the i guess the cristo
manosphere like christian manosphere
um called dalrock and dalrock and i were
um we're kind of like kindred spirits
way back then we started our blogs right
around the same time and so right around
2011 is when we started in and for a
while i wanted to actually put a
religious component into the rational
mail
but then dalrock did such a good job
with it that i was like
no i can't yeah this and it's too
complex and it's too you know
comprehensive and he did a better job of
it than i did and so i just kind of i
laid off of that but i was a regular
participant in on his uh his blog forums
and his uh his comment threads and stuff
like that
and
one of the earliest um
questions i always got about the
rational mail about either my my essays
and my my books later on was uh rolo i'm
a i'm a christian or i'm a muslim or i
am whatever faith and i don't believe in
pre-marital sex i you know i think that
marriage is the way to go blah blah blah
um how do i but i also can't deny that
what you're saying as far as like the
red pill awareness and everything else
is concerned is is definitely factual
and i can see it you know at play over
and over and over again but how do i
incorporate this into my life because my
convictions are such that i can't spin
plates or i can spin place but i can't
have sex with those plates
and so
it was this sort of back and forth that
was going on at the time between myself
and dalrock when we were we were talking
about this stuff dalrock i would not
necessarily characterize as like say red
pill in terms of like he's out there
being a player or you know gamer or
whatever yeah he was a married guy right
but yeah he was a married guy and i he
was yeah very much so uh the only thing
i know about dalrock personally is that
he lives in texas somewhere um and other
than that i've never like met him in
person
i tried several times to get him on my
show and uh he's just very very private
i don't know if that's a a work thing or
whatever
and then as of 2020 right around january
february of 2020 he decided he was not
he was done with blogging and he was
actually going to close up his blog and
popular demand he listened to everybody
and it's still up now he's not blogging
anymore but it's still there as an
archive and it's dalrock
d-a-l-r-o-c-k dot wordpress.com it's
just a free site but there's an archive
there it's 10 years of sort of this back
and forth and the other part that i
thought uh was necessary the reason why
i i put out a book on religion was that
that was one because i had so many
religious readers that really wanted to
know how they could make it applicable
or i would have them say like uh i'm a
i'm a christian or i'm an orthodox this
or i'm a jew or i'm i'm a you know
muslim or whatever and that's the real
red pill and we knew about this stuff
way back in the day and everybody just
sort of lost their way and so now you
know you guys are just rediscovering
what we knew for all this time it's like
that was an aspect of the book that i
covered and um i think a lot of people
misinterpret the the the intent of the
book because i'm it's not i'm not trying
to on anybody's religion or
anything like that
um
yeah in fact i made that try to make
that apparent from the introduction on
is that this is this is an analysis it's
not in fact if anything it probably will
piss off both the religious and atheists
as well
and in in some way and in some in some
parts you'll find it very affirming
depending on you know what your sort of
ideological position is
and then the lastly is i see and you
probably have noticed this as well
because we've talked about this over the
years on you know your show my show rule
zero everything else as there's this
trad con element right now especially
it's it's sort of coming up a little bit
more right now
um where they're trying to incorporate
the red pill into whatever their
ideological bent happens to be and it
first started like really in 2015 2016
and there was this it's for lack of a
better term it's really purple pill but
it's sort of a christian purple pill or
it's a religious purple pill and they
take just enough of the red pill
awareness and try to kind of you know
square the circle of their religion with
what the red pill says because it's un
ignorable it's hard for them to not be
aware of it so they've got to find some
work around i address that in there and
then also uh over the years dalrock also
covered a lot of um primarily like
evangelical but also catholics
um who were
you know trying to incorporate red pill
stuff into the inner sexual aspects of
their own religion so if it was a pastor
here or whatever they're they have a
real problem with it because they want
to be in control of it like
you